-Welcome back to
"Late Night."
We're here with Jason and Dave.
So, gentlemen,
you both have teenagers,
and I feel like you do
the kind of films
and the kind of television shows
that teenagers would love,
but I have often heard from
my friends that, sometimes,
kids can't separate
the fact that
it's their parents in shows,
and they don't love them much.
Do your kids like
the work you're doing?
-My son could care less.
I have not gotten any cool
points for being in movies.
He's more interested
in kind of YouTubers.
He's kind of into that thing.
You know, he's into rappers,
you know, ballers.
He's impressed by that.
Me, not so much, but it's
always kind of been that way.
He grew up with me, you know,
in wrestling.
He was that little baby with me
in the wrestling ring
and he just kind of
grew up with it,
and, like, I'm just his dad.
I think, more than anything,
he just wishes I was home more.
But, you know, as far as career
goes, no, he's not impressed.
-What about you, Jason?
-My kids love it.
And they're on set
with me everywhere.
I mean, you know,
they're friends with everyone.
They love --
It's always Uncle Drax.
They love, you know, Affleck
and Gal and, I mean, Ezra.
So, I mean,
they kind of grew up on it.
And thank God,
the first big movie
that they ever went to
was "Dune."
And it was really
heart-wrenching
sitting next to my children,
'cause it was pretty heavy.
But they're both like, "This is
my favorite movie, Papa."
So I'm -- It was really special
to take them to that,
so I'm excited for the world
to see it and --
But, yeah, I'm still in
the good books, man.
-Alright, I'm glad to hear it.
This was very impressive.
I guess this was you, Dave.
You basically just -- I think
a lot of people would say
it's hard to get a
project started in Hollywood.
You basically tweeted that
the two of you should do
a "Lethal Weapon"-style movie,
and it's basically -- everybody
just jumped right on board.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
You know, it's a
new one for me, as well,
and I just kind of put it
out there,
'cause, you know, sometimes,
I kind of gauge interest
on Twitter.
If you throw
something out there,
people automatically respond
like they're super-hot for it.
'Cause I thought
the idea was great.
And, you know,
I thought it was --
It really --
You know, Jay is so funny, man.
He's got such a charisma
and such an energy.
but I feel like it hasn't been
on full display
on films or television.
Then I thought about that,
'cause, you know,
we had talked about doing
another project together.
And I thought,
"Man, it would be great
if the world could see that
side of Jay, man,
'cause that side is just --
I mean, it's amazing."
But I always think
they focus on --
You know, Jay's got such a
great dramatic actor,
I think that really gets
focused on,
and they lose sight of,
you know, how funny he is
and how charismatic he is.
And I think it's -- You know,
it's something that
I wanted to be a part of.
So, anyway, that's how
the idea started with me,
and then I
started thinking about
the Riggs-and-Murtaugh
relationship,
and I thought
it's perfect for us,
because he -- I hit him up
and I said,
"Man, you can be
sexy and charming,
and I'll just be
old and grouchy.
It's just --
Like, it's perfect."
[ Laughter ]
-I will say,
you know, obviously,
we were introduced to you,
a lot of us, Jason,
on "Game of Thrones."
And you were very serious.
And there was
a photo recently from
David Benioff's birthday
with you and your co-star,
Emilia Clark, and I think this
is the side of you
that Dave was talking about,
the more fun,
the lighthearted side that we
didn't get to see in
"Game of Thrones."
-There he is. That's me, Seth.
My favorite show on Earth was
"Saturday Night Live."
I was raised sitting
next to that TV
and watching
"Saturday Night Live," yeah.
-The World's about
to see it, man.
-Now, I have to ask -- Dave,
obviously, we can see, today --
We actually have someone who
dresses like you on the show
named Mike Scollins.
He's a writer.
He has far less impressive arms,
but he is looking to get
his first tattoo.
Dave, what was your first
tattoo, and did you regret it?
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, it was -- So,
my first tattoo, you know,
I was -- It was
when I was really young,
and I didn't
want anybody to see it
and I especially didn't want
my dad to see it.
I didn't want to get into
trouble for getting a tattoo.
I was pretty young.
And, so, yeah, it was on my ass.
I got my tattoo on my ass,
and it was just --
It was really bad.
It was just cheesy, and I got it
from this old redneck
in Arlington, Virginia.
And I told him
where I wanted it,
and he, like, shaved my butt.
And then he's, like,
sitting in a rolling chair
and he rolls up to my face
and he goes,
"Man, are you sure
you want this on your ass?"
And I was like --
And I said, "Yeah."
So he put it there.
And like a week or two after
that, I just regretted it.
And I lived with it for years.
And I got, you know, ragged
on so much throughout wrestling.
Being in the shower one time was
like, "What's that on your ass?"
And I was like -- So I finally
got it covered up,
I think, around 2007.
I just got it covered up
with a --
-What the hell was it?
-[ Laughs ]
Remember, I was very young.
And this was also the '80s.
But it was this,
like, cement-looking heart,
and around it, it said,
"Heart of stone."
And when I saw it, I was like,
"Man, that's tough."
[ Laughter ]
-Heart of stone, man.
I love it.
-I'm still living it down, man.
-Yeah.
Also, I was alive in the '80s,
and that wasn't okay then.
[ Laughter ]
"It was the '80s, man."
-Help me out here, man.
Don't leave me hanging
all by myself here.
Support me on this.
-Hey, I want to thank you both
for being here.
Jason, I want to thank you
for being the one who asked Dave
what the tattoo was.
And thank you so much for making
the time for us today.
It was great
talking to you both.
-Yeah, man. Thank you.
It was a pleasure.
-Be well.
-The Season 2 finale --
-Momoa!
-The Season 2 finale of "See"
premieres on Apple TV+
October 15th.